recently I did a video titled 14
guerilla marketing tactics for
entrepreneurs and several of you asked
me Pat can you do one on how I can
increase my brand awareness of the
business or whatever that is that I'm
building so today I might give you 13
different tactics on how to help you do
that and so let me get right into it
point number one you hear PR publicity
often you know I'm a publicist how do I
get publicity look a few different
things you got to be thinking about
people want to know what your opinions
are people want to know what you're
thinking about now I'm not talking about
bashing and all that other stuff but
people know what you're thinking about
and so sometimes people say well I'm
afraid what if somebody disagrees what
if they do but you may have a big
audience that will agree because think
about who you follow yourself you follow
people with opinion whether it's sports
politics business no matter what it is
you want to hear people's opinions well
people want to hear your opinion as well
if you want to get your brand awareness
out there so how do you deliver your
opinion
it's either voice which is podcasts
every car now this has a podcast too
it's video Facebook YouTube so you start
making videos so number three is written
so you have a blog and you write about
what you're thinking about the other
part is start contributing for some
websites I can't tell you how many
websites I've written for literally if I
told you some strange website I've
written for I had zero presence online I
started very late on the social media
side many guys started early I was very
very late to the social media presence
some of the guys had a lot more edge on
that but it doesn't matter what it is
you can always get started start writing
you know ask to apply for Huffington
Post and contribute for them they
literally have an application for you to
submit to be a contributor for them the
other part about publicity is hiring a
PR rep sometimes there's a newer person
you may not be able to afford paying
somebody twenty five hundred bucks a
month or five grand a month or some of
the guys from New York and LA ten grand
a month but what I suggest you do I
would always tell PR reps listen if you
work with me and deliver for three
months I'll sign a long-term contract
with you what do you mean I will pay you
$500 per placement that's on this list
great you're making your PR rep work if
they say no they say no but if somebody
says yes and they do it they place three
in a month you're only paying 1500
versus three
dollars in a month so you can put him to
work the other part they can do is well
that's creative let's break some
Guinness Book of World Records we
literally call Guinness World Record and
I said I wanna break a Guinness World
Record and they said what do you want to
break I said well tell me some of the
things they have in mind we're thinking
about doing chess or checkers or
something like that they said well a
chess is being done but checkers you can
go out and this is the number that you
need to be that's a great we brought
down somebody that did the entire thing
it was regulated the doors were closed
and we actually hold the record we
brokered February of 2014 for the most
checkers players in a room you literally
if you go type this on Guinness Book of
World Record and you go on YouTube
you'll see this come up we broke the
record got a lot of publicity news was
there mayor Senators all these other
people showed up because they wanted to
be part of a Guinness Book of World
Record number two controversy have a
position that other people don't have in
your industry if you're saying what
everybody else is saying in your
industry no one's gonna hear you you got
to make some noise people I don't know
what you're doing people I don't know
how different you are and sometimes
you're gonna say something and all of a
sudden you'll get a loyal following
that'll come and say I agree with you I
wrote an article about how I don't
believe real estate is the American
dream I've never believed real estate
it's the American dream people got upset
about that I started talking about how
the life insurance industry's mainly
around white Caucasian they're not
looking at multicultural Hispanics
middle eastern Asian African American is
mainly dominated in that marketplace and
people said what are you saying I said
here's what you're looking at look what
Limor report is telling us what are we
gonna do to be connected to this
audience I disagree with you why are you
making this about race I'm not making it
about anything my wife is American I'm
just telling you this market needs help
I can't believe he said this I agree
with them boom people started contacting
and then magazines within the industry
wanted to hear about my controversial
point on that point number three every
once in a while every once in a while
you got to go for the home run these are
all singles doubles triples but every
once in a while you got to go for a home
run to be a game-changer look this video
is sponsored by fibra was recently
approached by Fiverr and the Yankees
Fiverr and the Yankees teamed up
together and they said look we want to
go out there and give an hour
/ - needed for entrepreneurs to get a
lot of publicity and brand awareness for
themselves I said what do you guys have
in mind and I was in Las Vegas when they
called them they started going through
the whole thing we are mainly working
with you you're the only channel that
are we going to be doing this on value
taming and here's what we're looking for
what is that tell me what it is for the
entrepreneurs we want to have different
businesses post a 30-second video on a
website about their business story and
we're gonna vote and pick businesses
five and then we'll choose the five that
we choose this is what we're gonna do
for them I said what is it they'll give
you four Delta Sky suite tickets for you
to bring three of your peers you and
three other partners that you have
you'll go to this suite at the Yankee
Stadium in front of 54,000 fans your
brand is gonna be shown on the big stage
for people to see while you're there
yourself with your three partners
everyone's gonna see it they're
designing that ad for you because they
like your story on top of that Johnny
Damon who's a two-time World Series
champion he wanted once with the Red Sox
he won once that yet with the Yankees
now he's an entrepreneur he'll be there
with you and then at the same time get
1,500 dollars towards fiber where you'll
have your own personal account manager
to help you take your business to the
next up you get all that stuff I said
you're serious yes what do they need to
do click on the link below it's on the
description side go on the link produce
your 30-second video on a vid on the
phone on whatever you got to make sure
is 30 seconds because the best about 30
seconds post it I'm one of the judges
it's about ten judges we're gonna vote
for it you have to submit it before
September 8 I believe right
September 14th winners will be chosen
September 18th is the actual game so you
got to make sure you get your video and
don't wait till the 8th because the
video is gonna be seen any minute the
moment this video goes out so that could
be a big opportunity for this to be your
home run imagine the videos you're gonna
get the recording you're gonna do we're
being highlighted in the Yankee Stadium
what if you get a chance for being
selected for one of these you're hanging
out with Johnny and all this other stuff
every once in a while you gotta for your
home go for your home run this could be
one of the ones for you to be a game
changer number four strategic
partnership cross-pollinate you've got a
business so you'll go to another guy say
what
we figure out a way to cross-pollinate
so I bring clients to you and you bring
clients to me what can we do here how
can we collaborate together there's a
lot of great partnerships out there you
can have number five influencing
influence or marketing I can tell you
this for me probably play the biggest
role in helping my business go to the
next one matter of fact I can guarantee
you it's number one on the list let me
explain to you why influencer marketing
I got started early on as a financial
advisor
I'm cold calling everybody no one's
listening to me I'm a Morgan Stanley
Dean would have got no one is listening
to me I don't have a for you I have
nothing going on so I'm calling people
with money on all these things no one is
willing to listen finally I got one
believer i sat down with them
he says you're a new broker I don't
believe you're gonna stick around he's a
twenty million dollar guy I kept
impressing him impressing him impressing
him impressing him the moment he bought
into it he bought from me then he told
all his hi influencers to do business
with me then I started getting bigger
accounts I have one influencer that I
had a relationship with who introduced
me to Tom who introduced me to our
biggest broker that we have in our firm
right now one influencer that did that
so I started having many centers of
influence meetings I set up 20 of them
these are 20 people a lot of credibility
and I would have meetings with them
every quarter I would send them books
send them give send them different
things after I was done meeting with
them and it was always about
establishing a relationship with them
eventually they gave so much business
because I helped them out things started
growing that's a direct these are people
I directly build a relationship with
some of the ones may be indirect you got
people online that may be willing to
work with you you got some people online
you'll approach nowadays it's so easy to
approach somebody I think it's if you
send a message to somebody that has 40
I'm gonna go after Kim you know
Kardashian and they got ninety five
million followers on Twitter if you go
to somebody who is 128 thousand
followers maybe a little bit higher
chances of them wanting to do something
with you 69 thousand followers 220,000
followers 7.9 million followers and
maybe too early for you to do that but
centers of influence influencer
marketing can do a lot for you you know
nowadays they're making movies with
Instagram accounts
was a girl or a guy that has a lot of
followers 2.9 million followers they're
taking seven of them total 20 million
followers I'm REMIC in a movie and
instantly these Instagram influencers
are saying go I'm in this movie go watch
this I'm in this movie and the movies
blown up and the budget was only eight
hundred thousand dollars or a million
dollars or two million dollars they
don't have to give a twenty two million
dollar contract to a Will Smith or a 36
million dollar contract to Johnny Depp
they don't have to do that they can get
these Instagram guys to get them going
in business you'll see a lot of guys my
friends Kelly Nishimoto used to be on
value taemin she would talk about how
her and I sat down one time says how do
I do this I said go find the hottest
girls would people girls that have nice
butts and this is your brand cute booty
is your brand and bring them a ton of
supply give them stuff to record a video
make a picture of them and that'll get
out to their audience they did that you
can do this with so many deaths it's so
easy nowadays if you have a tangible
product to do that today more than ever
before number six create Wow experiences
let me explain to what I mean by Wow
experiences okay perfect let me just
show you something that happens to be so
random and I'm walking away from the
camera but I'll tell you this so we're
in Vegas I'm out this has nothing to do
with anything but I'm going to show you
something
audible you guys don't even know what
I'm doing right now okay so I'm out
there my wife starts telling me how she
likes this specific ring okay but the
ring was different and I said what do
you mean it's different why I like I
wouldn't mind if it's slightly different
I don't find the zoom in so don't it's
gonna be fine so here's a ring right by
the way check this up you open it up
boom light goes off how cool is that
right so I like this ring I want that
blue stone I want the diamonds I want
this I want that I said okay I'm gonna
guess she has no idea sitting here by
the way she has not seen this video that
means I have to give it to her next few
days cuz it has to go out right Wow
experiences for everybody around you
this is family you can do this with
customers surprise them find out when
their birthday is their anniversary send
them strange funny gifts you know come
out of nowhere an emotional moment
introduce to people a friend they
haven't seen set up different things set
up a strange three-way conference call
and say gift so I have on the call I
wanted to call calling as a
as a CEO saying hello to cut there's so
many ways for you to have Wow
experiences you just have to pay
attention to signs and say what if I do
this that'll put a smile on his face on
her face on their face on this company's
face on this clients face let me make
him feel good about it and people all of
a sudden start telling that story to
other people say man that guy didn't do
it for me this guy did it for me you can
do that all this time we were at a
restaurant last week when I was doing
business with Oscar De La Hoya we're at
a restaurant last week maybe at last
week two weeks ago in LA I go to this
restaurant they got 13,000 reviews on
Yelp four starts very very well-known in
downtown LA I say I need to see her
manager right now and a waitress gets
uncomfortable and they're gonna say I
need to see the general manager right
now she walks away
everybody starts looking at this general
manager walking up to me I said what's
your name he says John suit it up
beautiful place I said John I just want
to tell you something and I'm talking
like says what's that I don't know what
you're doing here but the service here
is amazing I've been so impressed by the
service here you know Jenny here was
flawless I've never seen somebody served
the way she did she paid attention to
everything she brought the refroze I
never once had to ask about it it's very
obvious what you guys do was a flawless
job and you see him go like this are you
serious I said yes he says I thought
you're about to complain cuz that's all
we get I said I know you get it all the
time but I just wanted to tell you
whatever you're doing I'm taking notice
of it keep it up it's awesome they went
back they came back they didn't want to
take the money that's it this will keep
it I said no I'm not here to tell you
that I just want you to know Wow
great experience you can do it for
everybody all the time six I said
Brandon were number seven to establish a
unique personality you can have
characters there's a lot of different
ways you can do it you know progressive
has flowy Old Spice has that one guy
that you don't see it here and then I
look down look below you wish you saw
all this stuff you can have that guy the
Verizon guy who's now a sprint guy or
t-mobile guy he's hilarious right you
know where people recognize them there's
a lot of marketing being done with the
personality side this is a hidden myth
just so you know that it works at times
and sometimes it doesn't work number
eight referral programs affiliate
there's many ways to create affiliate
programs you give me a motivation to do
that
by the way it doesn't always work and if
you overdo it it devalues your product
but it works if you do it every once in
a while don't just count on this all the
time number nine social media contest
you know vote for this you know do a do
a tag for this tag somebody will choose
somebody this first person that comments
this first person that answers this
we're gonna give this away there's so
many Instagram contests you know Twitter
you can do the voting thing there's so
many different ways to do social media
contest now there's number number 10 do
an industry research and study paid for
by you spend fifty thousand dollars
thirty thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars pay your research firm let them
do it for you and then from there
explain it to them that this is done by
your company and everybody says oh my
gosh this is so great it was done by
this company yes let us share this
research with you infographic studies
polls all of these things that companies
do you can create this and your brand is
on it everybody within your industry
shares then knowing your brand is all
over the place because you did that
study brings you a lot of credibility
number eleven freebies giveaways hey go
tack three people I'll give you this hey
go share this and we'll give you this
hey go tack hey go and tell this story
post a video and we'll do this there's a
lot of different giveaways to be given
away number twelve hashtags and I may
explain what I mean by hashtags if you
go to insta the hashtag insta-awesome
it's not fifty million times right if
you go look for hashtag lifestyle all
over the place millions of people use
that hashtag don't use those hashtags
I'm talking niche hashtags niche to your
city niche if you're in a city that
nobody else knows Glendale Glendale is
only Glendale Arizona or Glendale
California but that's a niche so anybody
in Glendale they're on their phone
they're going through hashtags and you
pop up look for a niche a product like
Finance forget finance goal life
insurance you know real estate talk REO
short sale you know whatever it is
flipping flipping properties its Mitch
and then tag those like those
communicate with those comment on those
and you're following that small
community but don't be too general very
specific hashtags
and last but not least 13 exclusive
offers you can tell I pretty much ran
out of real estate here what am i
writing here exclusive offers
time-sensitive where you say in the next
24 hours if you do XYZ traffic everybody
goes to it in the next buy end of the
week I'm gonna choose this that that
everybody goes to it again this this one
here and the affiliate program those two
you can overdo it you overdo it it loses
value and nobody responds to it I
sometimes get an email from different
websites or people I have subscribed to
just kind of see their emails and it's
offers every day it's too much I no
longer even listen to it I unsubscribe
because it's too much some people
disagree with what I'm telling you I'm
just telling you for me brand awareness
if you're just looking at me as a sale
all the flippin time you're gonna lose
me I need you to understand there's a
relationship educate me give me value
entertain me give me a wow factor and
then make an offer to me that I wanted
to buy from you so having said all of
these things these thirteen different
brand awareness ones if you have a way
that you do yourself that I didn't cover
with your comment on the bottom if one
of these ways we covered with you got a
question about comment on the bottom if
you haven't yet subscribe to the channel
be sure to subscribe to the channel last
but not least if you haven't yet gone to
the website with fiber to be part of the
game change of contest the collaboration
between Fiverr value tainment
and the Yankees click on the link below
go post your 30 second video and then
share it get as many people to vote for
as possible so you can participate in
the game-changer contest with Fiverr and
the Yankees take everybody go by
[Music]
you